he's a car he's the green one you better
shoot that like a lot shoot it more yeah
there you go yeah you almost dead here
comes MLG Pro I'm so good you guys are
going down I'm not I don't have to be
intimidated by a thug like you mark yeah
oh sorry
jeez although Sam is how good I am and
how bad you're gonna be looking at those
cones like losers you were good you
check outside behind the shed he's
[ __ ] himself over I lost him in here
there will be blood yeah don't worry the
cackling maniacally but they're liars
about I'm watching silently who you
cackling at one
both of you know okay and you'll know
later on you're not you're not gonna
you're just dumb you're lacking
intellect right now who's down
which one's done I've certainly not me I
mean time will tell you gotta prove to
me that you're not dumb I'm gonna say in
this moment because I want to call you
dumb as a person I'll call Adam dumb as
a person yeah super smart this guy right
here
someone Oh ladies knocking down all the
barrels yeah I'm checking them all don't
worry now what would happen if I shot
one it sounds like stomp in the other
room I'm here okay mark all we have to
do is you should probably move right now
no I recommend you move no Adam you
doubted you doubted my Sally mix Aggie
today I was like two barrels left to
check and you just blew me up thank you
so much I didn't do that
dude you killed me I did not kill you I
can show you the footage I didn't shoot
a single bullet out of my gun I was I
was dead what do you bet happened so far
can't believe you guys haven't found me
oh well Undead so why not use how much
he killed himself
whatever one blew up by me I was running
for my life and then the other one just
blew up magically as far as the game is
concerned Sally mixed saggy tits and
maybe a mental imbalance and decided I
[Music]
wasn't there
context he's on your team man hi yeah
yeah exactly
I'm just gonna be blamed for this
forever more I get blamed for cheats
because it's a legitimate blame you may
be right
so if you become an explosive barrel can
you blow up no I don't think so
oh no that would have been the best does
that mean you're high you guys are
watermelon are you this is gonna make
you make you save your money already
found a mistake okay really really
psyched about this where is it all right
take your time take your time just
watching on in horror I didn't even
realize that you were in there mark yeah
I saw you ran by me I was like he's
gonna find me because you gasp sorry
maybe we should communicate his
teammates no maybe you should use your
telephone to talk to me oh ha oh ha hee
ha ha all right we'll see if they're
real dumb I think you greatly
underestimate our dumbness you guys
should be able to figure this out you
should like I'm really confident you
guys right now
okay well prepare to be disappointed
okay so why is that movie so what is
that movie I don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
you were talking stressed stop no gods
going on you check out the inside
what did you do Jordan oh what's wrong
to come into the the cleaver room my
fans
George leave ya the room with the knife
in the wall the kids oh I'd actually
don't know here the kitchen
it's about a [ __ ] pretty sure he would
make this mistake dear God I was trying
to become a model other than work in the
same yes that's the thing we have the
same room absolutely by the way a good
hiding spot i you are very very thank
you
is that sorry why would it be sarcastic
to you exactly exactly
[Laughter]
because I think you like real bad here a
lot of watermelon death um yeah I'm just
making sure he's not a watermelon make
it extremely sure that's important to do
you know
Oh mark what'd she do did he maybe he
got up on a shelf or maybe he's the
newspaper under the thing also you need
a note max that he failed earlier as
well yeah he failed pretty miserably
well which one of us failed definitely
George always scattered all over the map
wait a second why is the set of skills
oh dear I've been fooled skills that
make men like me and night never props
every 20 seconds the song they use for
that trailer should have been like can't
stop won't stop those two songs I don't
see we are typically frustrating me
[Laughter]
don't like it when I get frustrated that
sounds more like Harrison Ford right now
it's kind of changing my wife
[Laughter]
whoa okay watermelon
check it out no oh my god the door was
open okay okay no I'm fine you're fine
no I want to run in I mean okay I'll
close this door and then close the store
[Laughter]
[Music]
I was just like hiding behind trying to
get out of
[Music]
I just read it like you